when are you ready I'm ready I'm ready
who's that this is a coloring book there
is nothing weird or bizarre about it
other than it says the word magic on the
front of it there is actually nothing in
the coloring book I'm showing you you
see there's nothing in it but Ryan yes
will you blow on the coloring book
[Laughter]
let's let's see okay so the next stage
is so we've gotten how we have pictures
been we have pictures you have pictures
will you blow on it we awful small
caliber we talked about this
no it wasn't her wizard maybe for
full-on Marvel like with the potato
will you give us a spell Ben as a
pitcher yeah so you better than I do
do you get mistaken for Colin Firth do
you go in first
yeah who has me by an Oscar in at least
10 inches right a lot of decorum but
yeah sign up for a gym once and the
woman got on the phone she said I'm just
gonna sort out your membership and he
went yeah Colin Firth is here one of the
things about sort of being Johnny Depp
is people must you know want to come up
and say hi they want selfies and things
and I just wanted you have any sort of
sympathy for this because how young were
you when you met Iggy Pop your band was
supporting him is that how it what
happened yeah I was 17 years old we were
on tour we did sort of did a lot of
opening act stuff you know around and we
were we had two shows with Iggy Pop in
Gainesville so I mean he was one of my
euros so I'm 17 years old we do the gigs
with Iggy it's the second night I know
he's splitting I'll never see him again
I want to meet him but I don't want to
go music yeah I needed something
different so I got in kono in incoherent
me drunk pints is like vodka just to
work up the nerve to say something near
the otic which you shouldn't have to do
so yeah he was walking around with the
Beagle I don't know why after the show
you know lights wrong he doesn't know
why either so I thought and I just
started screaming he flop piggies
and a few other governors what you know
not sure what more rhymes with that so
he walked over to me this beamed a lot
of leash and he got like that close to
my face and I'm looking at piggy pops
blue eyes and it takes so much time and
he just says
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how come it sounds like JK Rowling has
just spilled her guts to you you know
you know stuff that he doesn't well no
I'm not sure we have it we haven't
cross-referenced this yet actually but I
when I was asked to play the part the
first thing I felt was my responsibility
was to meet JK Rowling and to question
her about the the backstory and the the
life of this incredible character
because he is hugely beloved and I felt
like it was a big responsibility so she
talked through his childhood a lot of
which we all know from the Harry Potter
books up to this point and she went a
little beyond but not hugely I mean and
most of what she told me was about
Albert's not about everyone else so I
you know I know a little bit I'm really
sticking to this don't talk about it
close don't pretend you stick to the no
really boring person you will not give
you an actual you get cast as young
Dumbledore the one thing you do know is
you live
all I have to worry about growing up
keeping that beer growing that's it yeah
yeah but the big reaction from sort of
confused reaction from fans here are
some of the tweets when it got announced
I mean Dumbledore just got 200% Jude Law
is playing a young heart and gay
Dumbledore next but as a beast I'm
sweating already
this this I think sums it up quite
nicely
Dumbledore more like tumble tan
[Applause]
[Music]
you